all right gunfire ringing out across the
board border once again the texas
department of public safety says
suspected cartel members were taunting
texas national guard soldiers by firing
shots over the border in roma texas
that's right and lawrence jones was on
the ground with texas officials getting
a first-hand look at the crisis and the
constant threat our border agents face
and he's here now lawrence jones with us
to discuss good morning family good to
see you
it was rough out there when it comes to
what these national guardsmen are
dealing with as well as uh the troopers
on the ground what you saw in that video
is essentially
so we can't confirm that they're a part
of the cartel we just know that the
cartel works with these people that put
it simply um
they were taunting this was about a week
ago where they were taunting uh the
national guardsmen
yesterday around noon they fired off two
shots at the national guard so the
governor has the texas rangers
investigating the situation
when i talked to my sources they put it
very simply during the trump
administration they were going on the
offense really going after the cartel
they made some headway of course the
drugs were still pouring in but the
cartels were in a defensive posture
since biden has been in office they've
got a little bold they're firing shots
you may have seen bill mollusian the
other day in the middle of a live shot
they had to kill that shot he's been the
best border border reporter on the
ground they started firing some shots
out
across the border now technic
technically you would think that the
america the united states would go on
offense when that happens they're not
and so texas is left to investigate but
as they tell me all the time off the
record that investigation stops at the
border it's not like you can have the
texas rangers go across the border and
handle an investigation so we got we got
our guys being shot at now and
biden and kamala are nowhere to be found
on this issue yeah it sounds like the
cartels think they they own this border
like they run it well they own it
because
it's not just people coming through it
is the drugs coming through it is the
human trafficking it's all one pot you
can't just say let the humans in and not
let the drugs and it doesn't work that
way so they're winning this fight now i
talked to the general he's the guy
that's over operation lone star he does
say they're going to send more men in
but the problem who's going to pay for
this i mean does texas has to continue
to pay for all of this stuff we're
running out of money to do this now
texas his credit has been great when it
comes to fiscal responsibility but right
now we have a semantics game going on in
bite administration they don't want
texas to be able to conduct these
arrests at the border they say this is a
federal issue you're right it is a
federal issue so get down here and do
your job uh and now you have the border
patrol that are like look we can't do
foot pursuits anymore we can't do
anything and they kind of depend on dps
to do that for them and then turn them
over so
it's a it's a lot of back and forth
earlier this week we had some footage
when i was on a
ride-along with the texas department of
public safety special operations unit
and you may have seen 60 illegals
that were captured on private property
so the guy calls texas dps he says look
come out here on the scene arrest these
guys border patrols
runs to go get these guys and they say
well essentially off the record we've
been getting a lot of flack from the
administration because texas is
essentially making us look bad they can
just simply do their job
and again to the border patrols for
credit they want to be able to do their
job the biden administration is not
allowing them to do that and so instead
you've got texas authorities finding
almost a loophole so they can arrest
people for trespassing inside the law on
private property that's exactly right
which is the misdemeanor essentially
which means they go to jail but they
can't once they have their hearings and
everything they can't pay their bill so
they end up staying behind bars after
they have done their time in texas
then they turn them over to border
patrol they deport them and these people
just come back tell me about these texas
dps forces who are these guys what is
this force like how big is it how what
is their training yeah so you have
regular troopers that essentially are
highway patrol they're doing traffic
tickets and things and you have texas
department of public safety special
operations unit which is essentially the
swat team
that are conducting searches when it
comes to the trains because they hide in
the trains um uh on private property um
but but the
they didn't sign up for this type of job
uh they are being placed in this
situation now they're willing to do it
but
when i talk with the folks that are on
the ground they tell me this and this is
why they're frustrated the people that
they're catching coming across they are
being very clear that the president said
that they could come
and you see a grown man yesterday break
down when i asked him how long have you
has it been since you had water and food
has been days that guy's in the hospital
now now i'm not saying or encouraging
people to break the law but when you
have the commander-in-chief saying it's
okay to come across the border and then
they get arrested by texas dps i just
don't think that's a humane position
where's aoc with the tears at the border
it would be nice for her to come to
texas and see the conditions that these
folks are are going through yeah or
those little girls you know four and six
years old all by themselves in the
desert with a little note and an address
for their aunt's house somewhere in the
united states and border patrol found
them thank god and not some pedophile or
some evil cartel who would put them into
sex trafficking i mean this is some
really terrible stuff shame on aoc for
not being in texas um when she showed up
for you know when the electricity went
out um was at the uh during the trump
administration outside of detention
centers crying where is she now where is
she now she's all
the last thing i'll say on this and
people are wondering how texas has the
manpower to be able to do this
texas just had its largest class police
class
for the texas state troopers all over
the country you see the demonization of
police and i feel like you always have
to preface them we should stop doing it
everybody knows there's bad actors
involved in it but if you don't say that
then they just slam you part of the
reason why texas is able to do that is
because they feel supported in the state
of texas they know that the guys out
there are doing their job and they're
trying to keep them safe they did not
sign up to protect a united states
border but again as i continue to say
the last defense of the country the last
defense of texas is the texas state
troopers the bottom line and they didn't
sign up for it it is a federal issue but
they don't want to do it good job it's
up to texas to save us that's amazing i
love it nice work great work great work
appreciate everything you're doing